Hi everyone.
Welcome to toxic Google.
My name is Dana and it is my pleasure today to introduce Tim League from the
Alamo Drafthouse.
Great to be here.
Uh,
so Tim,
do you mind telling us just a little bit about how you went from being a
mechanical engineer where they believe in art history,
minor or other major to this kind of movie theater mogul?
Well,
I think in order to answer that,
I have to back up a little bit.
I went to a high school that didn't have very good college prep,
so I hadn't really even thought about what my life was going to be.
We never did.
We didn't have any AP classes and I was good at math.
And so that's the only guidance.
I,
God,
if you're good at math and you just go into engineering and you sort of fall
into it.
So I studied it and then it was only through the course of four years of
education that I realize that the very,
very tail end after I'd done all the hard work that I didn't want to do this and
it was a horrible mistake.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
in the meantime,
I had been interning at Shell oil for,
and it was,
I was an awesome intern after I was a sophomore.
I had a really meaty project and I dove in and I just,
I didn't have any friends,
so I just was,
I worked all summer.
Um,
and uh,
then the next year I was a passable intern,
but they still remembering how awesome I was the year before.
And then by the time I graduated,
I was probably a worthless employee.
Um,
uh,
borderline dead weight.
Um,
and,
uh,
I knew that there was going to be something else to do.
So on my way to shell,
I was in Bakersfield,
California,
by the way.
I'm in the Central Valley and on my way to work was an abandoned movie theater.
And then one day there was a for lease sign on said movie theater.
And I had always loved movies my entire life,
but I just never thought that there was any possibility.
I didn't want to make movies.
I just didn't think there was a career for it.
Um,
but then that for lease sign said to me,
uh,
you could actually have a career or showing your favorite movies to people and a
week later I was in the movie business.
So,
um,
at 23 years old with no,
no real experience made things happen.
Yeah.
Just dumb and arrogance and it was
powerful.
Combo optimistic.
Yeah.
You can choose better adjectives.
Um,
so I mean you had one theater in Bakersfield and yeah.
You have 19 and are growing and you were coming to San Francisco.
Yes.
I eventually figured it out.
We didn't know how to do it in the beginning,
but yeah,
you definitely have figured that out.
Um,
so you guys have now expanded,
you're based in Texas,
but you have,
you know,
you're expanding now you're coming to the west coast and east coast in Brooklyn.
Um,
so can you talk a little bit about the San Francisco Theater?
Yeah,
I
was interested in expanding the,
the company at a certain point.
We were growing and we're growing and we were always an Austin based company.
And then,
um,
uh,
you know,
a lot of things happen with the company.
And,
uh,
we started this growth trajectory,
but then I started to think if we move nationally,
we could expand what we're doing.
We could like this idea of sharing movies that we love with as many people as
possible becomes more interesting if you look at it nationally.
And so once I made that step,
the first thing I wanted to do was to open up in some pretty serious markets
like Los Angeles,
New York,
and San Francisco.
But the three that I chose,
and that was five or six years ago.
And now we're finally opening up the first one of those here in San Francisco.
Um,
you know,
later on this year.
Um,
so you picked the,
I think gets the,
at the time,
the old mission theater not gonna be the new mission theater,
which is this kind of his store,
the hidden gem.
Well,
going to be a gem of a theater.
Um,
can you talk about kind of the,
the plans for it?
I know it was when it was once we,
I believe in now it's going to be several.
Yeah.
And so it actually made the name chains from the mission theater to the new
mission theater in the 20s.
And so it was a single screen sort of shotgun,
very small theater,
uh,
from uh,
with 98 years ago,
whenever that was a,
and then in the 1920s,
it was renovated and it,
they created this a movie palace and the back of the shotgun theater.
So the new mission is actually an 80 year old name,
90 year old name.
But,
um,
uh,
I first got a heads up about it from a,
just a friend of mine that was living in the mission.
So I was looking at other properties around the city looking at possibly new
development.
And this buddy of mine,
I guess went in there when it was a futon shop and you wandered past where
you're supposed to wander cause they just had futon stacked up in the lobby.
And then if you go past the last line of Futons,
you saw this glorious expanse of a grand old theater.
And so he called me and said,
you should think about this.
And um,
uh,
you know,
five years later here we are.
Yeah.
I think it's,
it's really great for dusting the area just because like a lot of developments
in San Francisco especially,
you know,
everything becomes something different and new.
And this is nice to be seen,
like see a theater being restored to being a theater,
a instead of a futon shop and serving its original purpose.
Um,
I think a big thing for me,
it seemed like the,
um,
you know,
Alamo Drafthouse community is being a part of the community.
Do you have any plans to kind of integrate into that area?
Yeah.
You bring the vibe of San Francisco to this theater or
we're just starting to hire and so that's going to be reflected in our hiring.
So we hired a,
our first creative manager position.
This Guy Mike Keegan,
who used to run the programming at the Roxy for a number of years and then he
left.
Uh,
he had this project he worked on last year,
um,
where he was touring this festival of cat videos across the country.
I don't know.
Uh,
uh,
and so he was looking for a Gig and I really like his experience and his energy
and so he's going to be programming a lot of the theater.
Uh,
we've,
we've just made an offer to somebody to be the,
our community liaison.
So it's basically working with the nonprofits and the film festivals in the
neighborhood and uh,
making the space available kind of as a community arts center.
And so that will be soon.
We hired a bar manager,
a sky,
Isaac Shumway who,
um,
uh,
was from Bourbon and branch and Tosca.
So we're trying to find people that fit with our aesthetic that are from San
Francisco that you don't know the neighborhood live in the neighborhood.
Mike,
the creative manager lives a block and a quarter from the theater.
He lives on mission like in the next block up.
So
working,
working out will be very intertwined for him.
Um,
is that something,
you know,
that you guys typically put a level of caring to all of your theaters?
Is that something that as you expand your finding harder to do,
or do you,
is that kind of a core mission of yours to make sure that that quality control
is,
is in every single theater that you opened?
Yeah,
it's the only way that the,
um,
that the project is exciting to me.
I mean,
we're,
we are,
we are a chain.
We had to go through all the hoops that you have to go through by opening a
business in San Francisco and being a chain.
And I hate,
I hate chains,
you know,
and so I don't,
I,
I'm in a strange position where I want to make sure that as we expand,
um,
that we do it in a way that feels right.
So in this,
it largely is built upon this idea of hiring,
um,
you know,
the chef,
the bar manager or the creative person in the creative,
uh,
the community liaison that live in the neighborhood know the neighborhood and
just letting go and letting them be,
it'd be a reflection of their personalities and not mine.
Is there,
is there kind of room to grow for each of the different sort of markets that
you,
you know,
do you allow them that sort of creative freedom to them or is there
absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean the,
the,
the menu is going to be rethought the farm and he was going to be rethought.
The programming's going to be a reflection of Mike's,
you know,
somewhat sick and twisted brain.
I don't know.
Um,
so,
you know,
they'll be some support that we offer from head office,
but really I want them to just kind of take on their own and take it and run
with it.
We,
we set some general guidelines and we hire people that we think are reflective
of our brand,
but then,
um,
it's,
there's to excel or screw up.
Let's,
speaking of your brain,
you guys have kind of gone from Juniata.
You're a,
you're a chain,
but you're also kind of this growing empire,
uh,
very cool things.
You know,
you've got Mondo,
which does amazing art.
Um,
you got to have fantastic best,
which is,
you know,
this amazing film festival and now you're distributing films.
Um,
you know,
how has it been kind of evolving from this single theater into this multiple
theater and this multi-headed kind of entity?
You know,
I,
it was all,
it's all been fairly organic growth in a way.
I,
uh,
I would love to say that I had a master plan to build at all,
but,
um,
you know,
Mondo for example,
which is the kind of art gallery and,
um,
a boutique posters side of the business.
I had some street facing retail at our first location.
It was about five feet by five feet.
And I said,
I'm not utilizing this.
So we started selling tee shirts and tee shirts,
morphed into posters and posters became an explosive category.
And so it was almost like an accidental business,
but we brought in people that were very passionate about,
um,
a very specific thing.
And you know,
those people are still not in creative control today.
Yeah.
That's like 10 years,
10,
11 years ago.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
All the Mondo.
Um,
so I'm used to be that.
So you've also got the distribution side.
Yeah.
Um,
can you talk a little bit more about that and kind of where that's headed?
Yeah.
Um,
so that was an offshoot of fantastic fest,
which is a genre film festival,
horror science fiction,
fantasy weirdo movies,
which is where my tastes have always kind of been a,
but then we would play these movies at the festival and there'd be incredible
films,
a lot of foreign language films,
and they would never find a home beyond the festival circuit.
And that was frustrating to me.
Um,
and there was one film in particular that I saw,
I got hired out to throw a party at Sundance.
And so I went and I watched a few movies and I watched a movie called four
lions,
which is,
um,
uh,
British television director,
producer that,
who this is his first feature.
And I was a huge fan of his TV work.
And I just went in as a fan and I said,
oh,
that'll,
that'll sell.
I'll see that somewhere down the road.
And then seven months later,
the movie hadn't sold and I just got mad.
And so,
uh,
I concocted another half baked idea to start a distribution company to work in
concert with a growing cinema brand.
Um,
and that movie was a jihadi suicide bomber comedy.
so,
you know,
obviously that's maybe touchy subject material,
but,
um,
yeah,
or niche audience.
Uh,
but it did well and,
um,
that spurred us on to,
you know,
try to find challenging,
unique films.
And also the goal really is to try to make sure that there's a young audience
for foreign language film and challenging film like that.
Um,
there,
there are certainly,
it was cool to go to see foreign language films when I was 18 and I don't think
it necessarily is anymore and I don't know why.
So I'm trying to make it palatable to younger people,
I think.
I think by kind of adding that experience factor to it,
you know,
it does help make it more appealing.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
but speaking of that,
I should have,
that's actually that I was trying to think of it.
Um,
so just speaking of experiences like I think you guys are also known for,
you know,
making these huge experience things a,
I think you just did jaw like 40th anniversary of jaws where people watched it
from the water.
Yes.
Um,
is that,
is that kind of something that you're thinking about when you're picking films
to distribute?
Like how can you make an experience or is that kind of a very separate,
uh,
thought process?
Yeah,
uh,
well the process for me is what will go to festivals.
A lot of times it's where we pick up most of the films we acquire.
Um,
we'll watch them at first.
We have to love it.
So we really only work on films that we love.
Um,
which strangely is not the,
the,
well,
it's probably not the best financial business model either,
but it's not the,
it's not the norm.
Um,
you know,
uh,
so if we love it,
then we go back to the hotel room and,
um,
we pound out kind of a marketing proposal.
It's like this is all the things we're going to do.
This is how we're going to make build awareness for this film.
And then we put together a financial model based on comparable titles and then
we make our offer and we can kind of pitch.
Um,
and sometimes you get it,
sometimes you don't.
Um,
we don't have a huge pocket book,
so usually if we don't get a movie,
it's because we're not willing to pay enough.
But have there been any that you've kind of had to weigh your role as a business
person and it and go like,
oh,
I really like this was kind of on the cusp and we're not sure if it would be
worth it?
Or is it always just kind of artistry first?
Well,
it's accommodated.
Artistry gets us to thinking about it and putting the model together.
The model can blow it up where we say,
you know what,
this doesn't make sense for us.
And so we've walked away from a lot of titles and there's titles that we've lost
because we're not willing to gamble.
I,
you know,
an extra couple hundred thousand dollars or whatever it is to buy a movie.
Um,
and if we would've written a bigger check,
we would have gotten it,
but it's already,
it's not the profitable side of the business for me.
You know,
I think eventually it may be,
will be if we get to be a bigger company,
but right now it's still,
um,
it's still pretty thin.
Do you have any thoughts to expand this to production?
Sure,
yeah,
we've actually dabbled a little bit.
Um,
I,
uh,
I coproduced,
two movies called the abcs of death.
Uh,
and so this also comes out of fantastic fest.
A lot of things come out of the community of fantastic fest.
And so we took 20,
25 directors that we knew from fantastic fest and we gave them a small budget
and a letter of the alphabet.
So every four minutes there's a death by that letter.
So real fast paced.
Um,
and then we did a,
uh,
worldwide contest to become the 26th director.
And the first one was really successful.
It's actually our most successful film we've ever been involved with that.
So we did a sequel and we might do a part three.
Um,
it was called the abcs of death to
a,
and then most recently we just,
um,
uh,
co produced a movie again of fantastic fest veteran.
And so there were four of us that put in a small amount of money,
uh,
under $500,000 budget to produce a horror film and uh,
called the greasy strangler.
Um,
and uh,
but we own worldwide rights on it.
So we're thinking if we cure rate well and I keep the budget tight,
um,
and we're basically a backstop for distribution as Drafthouse films,
then we can hopefully make these low budget films work and it becomes a,
you know,
uh,
a way for short film makers to step into the feature world,
for example,
which is this case,
I think you guys are great kind of safe space
for this sort of fringe ish.
Maybe not everybody's interest,
but like there's this huge fan base when these things and you know,
I think a fantastic lesson now this
drag was pretty versus it's going to be wonderful.
It's sort of like this guy makes films that are sort of vaguely reminiscent of a
Wes Anderson world.
But everything is sort of sickened,
decaying around the edges and everybody looks a little bit like a mutant.
So anyway,
sign me out.
Really funny though.
Um,
I think,
uh,
you know,
what are the other things you guys are great at though is also kind of
pioneering and like standing up for things.
And one of the things that you guys did last year was you screened the interview
when know when a very few people were willing to,
um,
can you talk a little about kind of the decision behind sort of standing up for
America?
I don't know.
Um,
it was just a funny,
it was a funny month and you know,
I know you guys were in involved in a,
uh,
in a sense in that same debate,
um,
in the same sort of risks I guess becoming forward on that movie.
But,
um,
you know,
it's,
it's a straight down the Middle Alamo Drafthouse type of movie.
I mean,
Seth Rogen comedies do well for us.
It's a good movie to drink beer too.
Um,
and I had seen it earlier,
I saw it earlier in the month.
We did a sneak preview with,
um,
uh,
with Seth Rogen and Evan Katz that came down.
Um,
and,
uh,
at the time,
they're like,
yeah,
you know,
it's a little bit challenging with the,
the leak from Sony,
but we're proceeding as normal.
And then the threats came out that any theater that would show it,
you know,
there would be a terrorist attack shown,
uh,
directed at the theater.
And so within a day,
I think the big majors,
the top five majors in us and Canada dropped out and pull the film and then Sony
quickly,
within a few hours of that said,
well,
because there are no theaters that will play the interview,
we're pulling it out of re release entirely.
And I think I come to decisions out of anger,
I guess a lot as a,
so that pissed me off a little bit because like,
Hey,
we're here,
you know,
we'll,
we'll do it.
And so this is just a couple of days before Christmas,
uh,
and I got on the phone with,
I'm part of this organization called the art house convergence.
You know,
we're not purely an art house,
but we have one foot and commercial in art house spaces and we're,
we love this organization.
And it was a great dialogue because the,
um,
it,
the interview became an art film because of the context and because of the
controversy.
And so all of these theaters were,
which are traditional art house theaters.
Uh,
within a day we had gotten commitments from over 300 theaters to say,
yes,
we will play this movie because it is important.
Um,
and then the next day we went public.
uh,
and you know,
took some interviews on the subject,
uh,
which made my,
my parents and my inlaws really nervous for,
you know,
just being quoted because it was,
it was really hungry.
They were hungry for anybody to talk about it.
And we were pretty,
pretty much the first theater to say,
yes,
we'll definitely do this.
Um,
so there wasn't a terrorist attack called on the theater.
whether the North Koreans were actually involved in any way,
shape or form,
and there remains to be seen.
I don't know.
Um,
but yeah,
it was great.
It felt great.
Um,
and,
and it gave the independent theater is a really strong voice to say.
And,
and that we're a part of exhibition in the U S and I think in the wake of that
like the art house convergence theaters have actually had a bigger seat at the
table where before it was dominated by regal AMC Cinemark and states.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
you know,
you guys have kind of set this quietly set the standard for it.
Like,
you know,
I see AMCs now have dinner and a movie,
but that was when you guys first like without that,
the hobbit face is like one of the most famous kind of dinner and a movie things
you guys do.
And,
and it's,
um,
you know,
it's interesting because like it's this kind of large corporations imitating
smaller groups.
But do you,
do you still find that like the core of what you guys do is sort of maintained
by this kind of care and loving sort of thing that you put into all of your,
like I used to,
I assume everybody who works for Alamo is as passionate as you are about the
things that they do for it.
That's what we aspire to for sure.
Um,
and we,
we invest pretty heavily in creative people.
So,
um,
I'm,
I'm not threatened by AMC offering dinner and a movie service and I actually
want,
I want everybody in exhibition tick care about this,
the experience,
as much as I do,
like it doesn't really matter what we do in the grand scheme of things.
We're a tiny little drop in the bucket,
but I want the action of going to the movies to be special forever.
And so that means everybody's got to be really good.
So
I think this probably comes up a lot,
but the kind of action of going to the movies and that experience being special.
I mean,
in film school we had a saying that there's a special circle in hell reserved
for people who talk during movies.
And you guys have kind of been leading this sort of not leading the charge,
but you are very vocal about that sort of sacred movie space.
I know that there was a leaked voicemail years ago with a very upset patron who
got kicked out.
Um,
do you find that now that you've kind of set your flag on this and like,
you know,
we don't tolerate this,
that people have kind of fallen into line and,
and treat their space with more respect?
Or do you still find their kind of incidents now because you guys have that
whole great PSA series and,
uh,
there's still incidences?
So like,
um,
uh,
it still happens that we have to kick people out of the theater and it's,
it's,
it's a pretty dicey proposition a lot of times.
Um,
you know,
uh,
but 99.9% of the time it's fine and we're so clear about what the rules of are
inside the theater and what the penalties and ramifications are for breaking
this social contract with us.
That by being absolutely clear,
clear,
and being known for a company that actually does enforce it,
it just kind of solves the problem.
So,
um,
we opened up the theater and upstate New York,
not upstate,
but just Westchester,
just north of um,
uh,
New York City proper.
And people are like,
oh,
it's,
you know,
it's all well and good in Texas,
but in New York you never going to get people to stop talking during movies and,
you know,
it's been mildly challenging at times,
but in general it's been fine.
We haven't had that much of an issue up there.
That's great.
Um,
I think,
uh,
I think one of the big things is like,
have you,
have you seen the kind of publicity you get from,
you know,
you are,
there are only a couple of,
at the end of the,
there are a good number of them,
but they're not necessarily,
you know,
there's not like a Alamo in every city.
Right.
But you do get a lot of kind of internet,
um,
Preston and there's an awareness.
Um,
do you find that,
um,
that's kind of helped you as a brand or do you find it challenging and that you
want to kind of go to maybe all of these cities but can't because there is that
kind of extra care needed to,
to open a new location?
Uh,
it certainly helped us to have some level of awareness going to into a new city.
I think San Francisco has been great because there's a decent pipeline of people
to go back and forth between Austin and San Francisco.
And so some people have had exposure in Austin.
Um,
you,
we have a,
he's not quite the same level of tech industry in Austin,
but you know,
it's,
it's not bad.
Uh,
and that's,
that's helped to have it be sort of seated with people who know the experience
and,
and we try.
We've,
yeah,
we've,
we've put together a,
um,
a website called,
well,
we just changed the name recently,
but birth movies,
death.
And so that's a national site where we talk about movies.
Um,
and to see it,
to my knowledge,
it's the only movie review a news website run by an exhibitor where all movies
are not awesome,
you know,
so it'll be,
in fact,
you know,
Devin for Archie who runs it,
he's kind of a curmudgeon and he hates a lot of movies.
Um,
but for me it's the only way to have any sort of integrity in that space is to
be present negative reviews of movies alongside positive reviews.
And
it's offering you an honest opinion as opposed.
Yeah,
yeah.
Filtered one.
Um,
is there any space that you haven't touched upon yet that you want to expand
into?
I'm,
I think I'm strictly forbidden from starting any new businesses,
so I have the correct answer is no.
Um,
uh,
on the Mondo side,
we're going to probably do next year,
we're planning to do some more apparel.
Like we have a,
we have a big line of holiday sweaters coming out,
uh,
guess to start doing twice as well.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
finally shipped.
This is a funny business with,
with those kind of boutique toys,
uh,
you know,
you take preorders and then it's so expensive to do that and it's so intricate
that the product doesn't ship for 16 months,
which that's alien to me.
That's not how I buy things.
I want it in two hours.
So
when you came in the mail,
it was so exciting.
Yeah.
Um,
do,
do you kind of find that,
you know,
you're having to apply different sort of expectations of the different parts of
the business?
Um,
you know,
as you said,
it takes like 16 months to make a toy,
but it takes years to build a theater.
Yeah.
And I think in the early days when we were building new theaters,
um,
uh,
we,
it was a lot faster for us and it was in our own backyard.
And actually Texas,
at least back then.
Um,
it's not that it was the wild west,
but it was a lot easier,
a lot fewer constraints in terms of the development process.
And so,
you know,
doing a full interior exterior historic renovation project in San Francisco,
um,
is about the most radically different ends of the spectrum to what I used to do.
Um,
so I,
south Lamar,
which is our kind of flagship theater in Austin,
I had the idea to open that theater and from idea to opening day with six
months,
and we had,
we built the whole theater.
Um,
it was just fast and it was no,
nobody standing in my way.
Uh,
and here it's,
you know,
this is more of a five year project and so,
um,
but that's fine.
Um,
and some other things to keep you busy.
Yeah,
it's all good.
And San Francisco did something really interesting.
And then the reason why we're able to have the mission as a project is that that
historic theater spaces are generally really well protected.
So there's only a couple of things that that space could be remodeled into.
It could be like a live music space or it could be a theater space.
I'm not sure how the futon shop worked,
but um,
but they didn't read the,
you know,
they,
I don't hit yeah,
everything we want to think about that.
But uh,
uh,
but it was,
they couldn't massively redevelop that into something else because it's an
important historic structure.
It's the same architects that built the backside that built the Castro and it's,
you know,
San Francisco architects.
It's,
it's worthy of preservation.
Thank you for presenting it.
Yeah,
no problem.
Bringing new life to it.
I think we're going to open up to audience questions.
Sure.
Must've been considered to,
allows others to come in and not interrupt their viewing experience.
I don't know.
I just felt like there was a lot of the wedding and you seen something like that
before or how,
how did that come up that conceit?
Sure,
sure.
The question is basically the,
the specifics about the Alamo Drafthouse from the table configuration to the
service model.
How much of that was preconceived?
Um,
and if there are any inspirations,
uh,
there's definitely a one big inspiration and,
go back to the first theater in Bakersfield,
which by the way,
was it,
I didn't mention that it's a total unmitigated disaster.
It was a horrible,
uh,
horrible,
that's me,
sorry.
Horrible experience in a lot of ways.
Great experience because I learned the business,
but we,
we,
it just failed.
It was a failed business in every possible way.
Uh,
but during that,
um,
my girlfriend and I,
we got married in the middle of it.
It was this courtship trial by fire.
You know,
we,
we lived in the theater,
uh,
and we worked every single day.
And so we never left the theater and it was incredibly stressful because we
weren't making any money and we figured we still love each other.
And,
uh,
so that's,
I highly recommend that.
Did like work through a failed business together and see if you still want to
get married.
Um,
but our honeymoon,
we went up to Portland to go spy on a McMenamins theater,
which has kind of a food and beer model.
It's a little bit different than what we do.
Um,
but we had heard about it and we're already making plans knowing that
Bakersfield,
we could sense the Bakersfield was going to eventually truly fail,
um,
that we were gonna try to rise from the ashes and do things a little bit
differently.
And so,
um,
we checked out what they did on it was a working honeymoon.
Um,
well we,
we visited a bunch of their theaters and then we,
uh,
when we finally shut down Bakersfield and moved on to Austin,
we spent about six months workshopping the menu and,
uh,
the table configuration and the service model,
how it was all going to work in it.
That really hasn't changed too much since the very early days,
so that I can actually say we,
um,
did plan ahead and that it worked too for the most part.
I had a question how you encouraged to be different sizes of the theaters.
I guess the mission,
there's only going to be fewer screens then in the mini and Austin,
like event impact,
the types of shows do you film or that you'd scream?
How'd,
how do you sort of approach the different venue space configuration?
I think the question is how do we approach the different venue spaces in terms
of the sizes of the theaters,
the number of different auditoriums in each project.
For the mission,
we,
we can't change too much.
I mean the mission was configured to have a main room and then two balconies.
So we kept the main room in tact and we subdivided the first balcony into three
little tiny micro theaters that are like 35 seats each.
And then the second balcony is about,
it's a larger room with about 120 seats.
And then the main room has about 300 seats.
Um,
so,
uh,
then we have to pass that by historic,
um,
to get their approval for our plans.
And so they approved that design.
And then we'll build a financial model to see,
you know,
based on our fill rates for various sizes of rooms,
how much top line revenue are we going to generate and how much net profit are
we going to theoretically have with those types of rooms.
I wish we had more seats at the mission when we're building from scratch,
like we're building from scratch and um,
Brooklyn.
And so that has more like 850 seats as opposed to 550 and the mission and we
have eight or nine theaters.
Uh,
but what the mission does have is,
is what I like is having this range of,
of rooms.
So having 35 seat theaters allows me to be able to program some pretty esoteric
films.
So if you play something,
you get 25 people in a 300 seat room,
it's a complete disaster failure.
But if you have 25 people in a 35 seat room,
it's a total win.
And you can,
those are the type of movies that you can build if we're word of mouth.
And those are the type of movies that we buy.
Two.
So we'll play some Drafthouse films,
titles in the smaller rooms,
um,
and we play a mix of independent and a commercial.
So,
you know,
we're going to open up,
right.
You know,
hopefully.
Uh,
and then on the short horizon will be Star Wars.
So we'll play star wars and,
um,
I think I went on the black this people are excited about that movie and the
people are going to go,
but I don't know what do I know?
Big Fan of one,
two,
three in Austin and convince me go there every time and I let him walk away from
the original one.
So I think my friends,
honestly,
that was in the,
they're always saying,
okay,
when is it going to open
and keep up on the website so they turn to home that he think that this year
it's going to happen.
So the question is,
when are we open up the dam,
San Francisco theater,
four words to that effect.
Uh,
it is a work in progress.
It,
it,
it better be this year,
um,
you know,
out in the 2016,
yeah,
I think,
um,
we,
there's word here,
so knock wood is this word.
I,
they might have drinks at this plastic.
Um,
if we pass a lot of the hurdles that were really holding us up.
So,
um,
and honestly I make it sound like it's been arduous.
I mean it's been challenging for sure,
but it's,
we went into it with eyes wide open.
It's a historic renovation project and there's a lot of,
um,
forces at play.
So,
uh,
it's not that much more arduous than we thought it was going to be.
And it should be arduous,
right.
To,
um,
uh,
to bring in a project like this.
Uh,
but yeah,
it should be open before the end of the year.
Uh,
I don't know.
I don't have a firm date.
Um,
but there was,
um,
they're also doing construction on a Bartlett street right behind it,
a major,
major road construction.
And so there were utility tie-ins that had to happen to which we did.
There was her beyond our control.
Those are all happens.
There was a storm water runoff issues on the front legs digging above the bar
line.
We,
which,
uh,
you know,
it took us about nine months or so to get the permits,
but those have been issued.
So we can do that.
And those were the two things that were keeping me up at night and we're past
those.
Um,
and uh,
the progress is much more rapid.
How it actually get depressed if I would go maybe a year ago or nine months ago
and I go onsite and it's just not,
not much happening because nothing much could happen.
Uh,
uh,
but now it's moving fast as lots of people there and it's,
you know,
we're putting up sheet rock of all things and that's usually a sign that
everything in the walls is done usually.
Um,
so I'm very,
I'm very optimistic and I'm not going to give you a date
as well.
And I'm just curious that the genesis of the publications
I got it looks like
to be part of.
So question is how did the,
how did it come about both the website and the magazine?
Birth,
movies,
death.
Um,
so it's run by Devin for Archie who used to be with chuck [inaudible] who was a,
he's a great writer.
I've always liked him and I became friendly with him.
Uh,
sometimes it's dangerous to become friends with journalists,
but I,
I,
I do it regularly.
I like to talk about film.
I like to debate film and he's one of the best people to have a post movie
conversation with.
Uh,
he was staying at my house for a 24 hour movie marathon.
We do every year called button number thun.
Um,
and so we were actually sitting on the roof,
uh,
late at night,
probably drinking something,
beer or scotch,
I don't know.
And um,
I asked him,
I was like,
well,
how much do you make?
Which is a completely inappropriate question to ask him about it.
It was really curious and he told me it was like,
oh,
I think this is doable.
Um,
uh,
and so they really,
that's it.
That's the genesis is,
um,
I really,
I respect it as writing.
And that was at the time when we had made the decision to build out the brand
and to expand beyond our own backyard in Austin.
And it was a plan at that time to put together a movie discussion sites that
would help spread the word about who we are.
Um,
and,
um,
I didn't interview anybody.
I just asked Devin if he wanted to quit Judd and start this with us.
And he said,
yes,
I am ready right now.
Let's do it.
Um,
and the magazine,
um,
it seems somewhat silly to start a magazine in this day and age,
uh,
but we were also a brick and mortar restaurant,
or not restaurant,
but a business that has a restaurant.
And right now with a 19 theaters,
we have about 700,000 people that come through our doors every month.
And so that's just a,
that's a pretty nice stream of people.
So we can sell ads to pay for the cost of the magazine.
Um,
you know,
maybe we'll get that.
There's goals to make it a little fancier for digital consumption.
Um,
but that's,
uh,
yeah,
I like a lot of things.
We,
we budgeted it and said,
we can afford this and it makes sense and it helps the awareness of the brand.
So let's do it.
Who doesn't staff,
it's some the best.
Thank
you.
Mediocre.
But he didn't find his calling until,
you know,
he didn't he go through like a couple of roles and then,
yeah.
Yeah.
Justin,
um,
uh,
he was,
I knew him from the film collecting world.
Another sort of strange little facet of the business is we have,
we have a nonprofit film archive.
So in the digital transition film is just being discarded.
So I am,
I know I should have probably a support group,
but I'm a compulsive collector.
I always have been.
I've always had collections.
And then once I got into this business,
I started collecting the heaviest thing you could find,
which is all 35 millimeter film.
So we have about 4,000 prints.
Um,
and we loan them out to universities and theaters all over the country,
all over the world.
Um,
Justin was probably 24 years old and he was living in Kansas City,
which was the central hub of the film distribution.
So it was like you had New York,
Los Angeles and Kansas City,
Kansas City sent film out to the heartland.
And,
um,
so all of the best film collectors are right at Kansas City.
Um,
because the guys that are in charge of cutting the films in half and destroying
them or putting them in the dumpster,
there's this little legion of leeches that would sort of pull a few covertly out
of the,
out of the dumpsters.
Um,
so,
uh,
he was a film collector.
We traded,
um,
he came down for events and then eventually,
uh,
asked for a job.
So,
but yeah,
he started out as,
um,
bartender and there was a projectionist.
He worked in,
uh,
our outdoor screening company and he worked in venue rental sales and wasn't
really awesome at any of them,
but he really loved,
um,
uh,
the,
what was starting to happen at Mondo with posters and artwork and collectibles
and toys.
And once he found that spot,
he really flourished there.
Kudos for kind of
building this space for people who are passionate about film and going to see
films and you know,
for them to go.
And check out awesome movies.
Uh,
well,
thank you so much for joining us today.
It's my pleasure
guy.